[Música]
japón es un país que puede presumir de
dos cosas la primera es que tienen
máquinas expendedoras de ropa interior
usada por la calle la segunda es que
tienen la tasa de inmigración más baja
de todo el mundo desarrollado para que
os hagáis una idea un país como españa
tiene un 14% de población inmigrante
canadá o nueva zelanda tienen un 20 y un
25% respectivamente pues bien japón no
llega ni siquiera al 2%
y esto se explica porque tienen una de
las leyes de inmigración más
restrictivas que existen en otras
palabras japón sería el país perfecto
para donald trump o marine lepén y
porque os vamos a hablar de japón hoy si
hay algo que ha caracterizado al menos
políticamente el año 2016 ha sido la
palabra inmigración en europa el debate
sobre los refugiados todavía sigue
abierto y parece que la opinión
mayoritaria es que los inmigrantes son
un problema que hay que frenar que
nuestros gobiernos no pueden dedicarse a
gastar dinero para mantener a eso que
llaman la presión migratoria ahora mismo
está la presión migratoria entre 2008 y
2014 eeuu gastó 128 mil millones en el
control de la inmigración es que el
buenismo está en este punto no tiene sus
minutos pues bien japón es el ejemplo
perfecto de lo que significa vivir en un
país sin inmigrantes y os preguntaréis
qué efectos tiene esto en su economía
realmente consiguen ahorrar dinero al no
tener que pagar todas estas políticas de
integración para los inmigrantes
es fácil encontrar un trabajo para los
japoneses al no tener que competir con
la mano de obra extranjera hoy vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a explicar en qué consiste
la ley de inmigración japonesa
[Música]
un país una cultura una raza esta frase
fue pronunciada por el que fue primer
ministro de japón a mediados de los años
80 yasuhiro nakasone y condensa a la
perfección la política de inmigración de
japón básicamente hay dos formas de
entrar en el país del sol naciente con
un contrato de trabajo bajo el brazo o
con un visado de turista y si una
empresa decide contratarte desde el
extranjero aún necesitas un visado y ese
visado solo te lo darán si tienes una
titulación universitaria de alto nivel
algo tan específico y tan cualificado
que sea prácticamente imposible de
encontrar en el mercado laboral japonés
si por ejemplo eres un trabajador de la
construcción que va a resultar
prácticamente imposible entrar en el
país a no ser que te acoja a este otro
sistema con bien japón como no tenía
otra forma de aceptar a profesionales
venidos de países tercermundistas
asiáticos como puede ser vietnam o
filipinas creó un sistema especial de
entrenamiento que le llaman el technical
interno train
program lo que se llama en japonés el
vino
en resumen es como si te fueras a
trabajar de becario a japón pero
cobrando la mitad del sueldo que
cobraría a un becario japonés pero no
sólo eso es que además con este programa
de entrenamiento técnico tu jefe puede
requisar te tu pasaporte y hasta acceder
a tu cuenta bancaria es más desde que se
ha empezado a poner en marcha este plan
miles de inmigrantes asiáticos han
desaparecido
cuando el representante del sindicato
habló conmigo me dijo que tenía una mala
actitud y que si continuaba así su amiga
contrataría a un sicario para matar
nosotros sobre todas las polis
pero qué pasa si entras con un visado de
turista pues bien en este caso te puedes
quedar en japon durante un año y medio
siempre y cuando puedas demostrar que
estás estudiando japonés una vez ha
pasado este tiempo necesitas que una
empresa japonesa te contraté para tener
tu visado pero ojo a diferencia de otros
países como eeuu o la unión europea este
visado incluye también tu categoría
profesional es decir que si tienes un
visado para ser chef de cocina en japón
no puedes trabajar de otra cosa que no
sea un chef de cocina de otro modo no
volverán a renovarte el permiso así que
desde el punto de vista práctico sólo
hay un método para poder vivir en
japonés lo más fácil que tenemos aquí al
menos en japón para residir es casarse
con una japonesa así que ahora
entendemos cómo es posible que en un
país que tiene más de 127 millones de
habitantes sólo dos millones sean
extranjeros ahora vamos a ver qué
consecuencias tiene esto en el día a día
de los japoneses
el día
pensiones de los japoneses japón es el
país más anciano de la historia esto no
es porque tengan una larga historia que
la tienen sino porque su media de edad
es la más alta del mundo de hecho se
estima que en sólo 90 años habrán
perdido a más de 44 millones de
habitantes que es casi la población de
españa en principio esto no tendría por
qué ser ningún problema si no fuera por
la seguridad social como sabéis en casi
todos los países del mundo el sistema de
pensiones funciona de tal forma que los
que están trabajando en este momento son
los que están pagando las pensiones de
los jubilados de hoy en día si la
población activa decrece año tras año
cada vez hay menos gente pagando las
pensiones y más gente cobrando las y eso
explica cosas como están
las contribuciones a la seguridad social
sólo cubren el 60 por ciento del gasto
en pensiones el resto viene de impuestos
por cierto que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de mescalina un
grupo de rock de león en españa que nos
ha enviado su música si os gusta
encontrareis más links en la descripción
[Música]
y no sólo eso japón está subiendo sus
cotizaciones a la seguridad social año
tras año lo mismo pasa con los impuestos
y sin embargo siguen siendo incapaces de
hacer frente a sus gastos de hecho a día
de hoy japón es el país con más deuda
del mundo su deuda equivale a más de dos
veces su producto interior bruto y su
déficit fiscal es decir la diferencia
entre lo que ingresa y lo que gasta es
más alto incluso que el de españa en una
palabra como angela merkel se pase un
día por japón' les va a echar una bronca
que ni te cuento yo os preguntaréis esto
qué tiene que ver con la inmigración
pues mucho todos hemos oído hablar de lo
caro que resulta acoger a inmigrantes en
un país verdad hay que pagarles cursos
de integración políticas sociales etc
pero se habla muy poco de lo que cuesta
un ciudadano local por ejemplo un
ciudadano español desde que nace hasta
que cumple los 16 años le cuesta al
estado más de 132 mil euros
todo esto es solamente lo que gasta en
colegio y médicos a esto habría que
sumarle otro tipo de gastos es decir que
el estado invierte en cada ciudadano un
montón de dinero que sólo empezará a
recuperar el día en el que esa persona
pueda empezar a trabajar y pagar
impuestos que en españa- como mínimo son
los 16 años
sin embargo un inmigrante que llega a un
país ya ha pasado por el colegio y ya ha
pasado por la consulta del pediatra y en
alrededor de dos años de media
encontrará un trabajo por supuesto que
muchos de esos empleos tienen una baja
cualificación y están mal remunerados
por lo tanto el estado recibe muy
poquito dinero de los impuestos pero
como no ha tenido que hacer
prácticamente ninguna inversión es
prácticamente dinero gratis para los
gobiernos como japón no tiene
inmigrantes pierde esa oportunidad de
recibir dinero gratis y de hecho eso
explica por qué en mitad de esta crisis
fiscal el primer ministro japonés shinzo
abe hiciera esta declaración en el año
presionada a aceptar más inmigrantes
ante el hundimiento de su población
activa pero ojo porque aunque no lo
parezca este no es el mayor problema de
japón en realidad el gran desafío de la
economía japonesa es lo que llaman la
década perdida que es que llevan 20 años
sin crecer y en este caso los
inmigrantes también tienen algo que
decir
el país que viajó de innova todos
imaginamos a japón como un ejemplo de
país innovador y vanguardista
recordaréis compañías como nintendo
toshiba o song
el problema es que todas esas empresas
son viejas nintendo fue fundada en 1889
toyota nació en 1937 es más alguno de
vosotros sería capaz de nombrar me cinco
empresas japonesas creadas en este siglo
seguro que os costaría una barbaridad
sin embargo no tendríais ningún problema
a la hora de citarme a cinco o incluso
diez empresas norteamericanas surgidas
en los últimos diez años
los inmigrantes han fundado el 52% de
las empresas de silicon valley entre
1995 y 2005 las tasas de emprendimiento
en la población inmigrante son entre 2 y
3 veces más altas que las de la
población local y esto es una tendencia
que se da en todos los países por
ejemplo uno de los fundadores de google
sergey brin era un inmigrante ruso que
había nacido en moscú y el cofundador de
whatsapp janko un es ucraniano
pero no solo hablamos de las startups de
silicon valley cualquiera de los que
veis este vídeo desde españa podéis
salir dar una vuelta por vuestro barrio
y veréis montones de restaurantes y
tiendas chinas de kebab paquistaníes de
toda clase de empresas y negocios
fundados por rumanos y búlgaros y además
es que tiene bastante lógica que los
inmigrantes sean más emprendedores a fin
de cuentas desde el momento en el cual
dejan su país ya están demostrando que
no tienen miedo al riesgo pero no sólo
eso además un inmigrante trae una
cultura totalmente distinta y por eso le
resulta mucho más sencillo aportar ideas
nuevas en la economía en la que vive
ejemplo cuando charles feldman llegó a
nueva york a mediados del siglo 19 se
dio cuenta de que en esa ciudad
necesitaban comida rápida y así es como
se le ocurrió la idea de importar
salchichas de su alemania natal y crear
lo que hoy conocemos como el perrito
caliente hoy en día este producto da de
comer y paga las facturas de millones de
personas en todo el mundo y sí ya sé que
es un ejemplo muy sencillo pero es que
podremos encontrar miles a lo largo de
la historia en una palabra cuando las
culturas se mezclan surgen nuevas ideas
de hacer las cosas y nuevos métodos de
trabajo y esto es lo que en el mundo
empresarial se llama innovación y ese es
el ingrediente especial para que las
economías puedan volverse más
competitivas
[Música]
y los que seguís visual polític desde
hace tiempo recordaréis este vídeo en el
que os contábamos cómo israel se ha
convertido en uno de los mayores hacks
de innovación del mundo entero gracias
en buena medida a su población
extranjera y os preguntaréis qué ocurre
en japón pues resulta que es el país con
la menor tasa de emprendimiento del
mundo desarrollado sólo un 7% de su
población
emprende en comparación con el 10 por
ciento de canadá o nueva zelanda el
sueño de todo japonés no es crear su
propio negocio sino entrar a trabajar de
por vida en una de esas grandes empresas
como sony o toshiba y por supuesto estas
grandes corporaciones mantienen las
mismas estructuras corporativas y los
mismos métodos de trabajo de los años 80
las empresas tradicionales de
electrónica como sharp sony incurrieron
en tremendas pérdidas y miles de
despidos mientras apple o samsung
continuaban creciendo en bolsa si
recordáis hace unos meses sacábamos otro
vídeo en el que os hablábamos de los
patrocinadores de la eurocopa 2016 y
recordábamos como hace 20 años había
como mínimo dos empresas japonesas en la
lista de sponsors este año no había
ninguna y es que da igual el sector
donde miréis en cualquier industria las
empresas japonesas tienen muchísimos
problemas a la hora de competir con las
firmas estadounidenses europeas o
incluso las chinas y la razón no es la
falta de dinero sino la falta de
innovación y todo esto explica por qué
la economía japonesa lleva 20 años
paralizado
y por supuesto no os creáis que esto no
tiene un reflejo en el día a día de los
japoneses para poder mantener un mínimo
de competitividad frente a las empresas
extranjeras los trabajadores japoneses
tienen los horarios laborales más largos
y las vacaciones más cortas de toda la
ocde y por supuesto siguen cobrando el
mismo sueldo prácticamente que cobraban
en los años 90
creéis que japón debería abrir sus
puertas a la inmigración seguís pensando
que los inmigrantes son un problema para
los países que los reciben
podéis dejarme vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios y no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros al canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones como siempre si queréis
profundizar más en este tema
encontrareis varios links en la
descripción si os han gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
el camino lento
[Música]